- THEY'RE A STEP
AHEAD OF US EVERY SINGLE TIME.
- OH, ABSOLUTELY.
- A STEP AHEAD EVERY--
- DICKNANIGANS.
[somber ambient music]
♪
[honks car horn]
[crash]
- NO.
both: MM-HMM, MM-HMM.
- [whispering]
DICKNANIGANS.
- IT'S AMAZING.
[indistinct chatter]
- WORMS!
[somber ambient music]
♪
- DICKNANIGANS.
- IT'S A DIALOGUE
WITHOUT DIALOGUE.
- ABSOLUTELY.
I FEEL LIKE THEY'RE IN MY HEAD.
[Debussy's Clair de Lune
playing]
[gentle piano music]
♪
- [imitating a metal spring]
[gasping in appreciation]
- DICKNANIGANS.
- WOW.
- [whimpering]
POOP.
- DICKNANIGANS.
- FRISBEES.
- SO--
[guttural sounds]
- DICKNANIGANS.
- SOLANGE.
- DICKNANIGANS!
- OH.
[audience cheering]
- GENTLEMEN,
"EXPLODED NUTS SYNDROME"
IS A CONDITION
INDICATED BY THE PRESENCE
OF EXPLODED NUTS,
WHICH YOURS ARE.
BY THE WAY,
I SAW YOUR SHOW LAST NIGHT.
AMAZING.